next on the Dave Ramsey show is Mary
from Dallas Texas Mary how can we help
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call okay my husband and I were
routinely in the habit of sucking away
10% of everything we made into our
savings but for whatever reason the
strangest thing keeps happening every
time I get our savings up around $2,000
or you know like thereabouts like a
little above 2,000 something always
happens it's either a series of small
some things that take large chunks out
of our savings for it's one big
something that takes it all in one fell
swoop to the point where I just finally
throw up my hands and said we're not
saving any more there's no point
we've lost thousands and thousands of
dollars doing it this way and it's just
I'm fed up so fed up well Mary every
time what I know huh what are some of
the things that pop up all the time give
me give me give me a list or an idea of
the last four or five oh my gosh um uh
it varies it's literally always a
various host of reasons and it's not the
typical ones that you would think of not
like like okay caught breaking down or a
medical emergency nothing like that if
all these oddball weird things that just
seemingly come out of nowhere the last
hit that we had to take is we got
screwed over unfortunately by our bank
tour at first I thought the claim with
them and I was totally expecting them to
tell me you know no there's nothing we
can do about it when they told me yes
like okay no problem okay accredited
back a very large sum of money to us but
then less than a month later they
reverse their decision and so we had to
come up with enough money to cover them
pulling it out of our account otherwise
would have decimated
okay our entire bank accounts for both
our checking and savings would have been
in the negative it would have been
horrible okay Mary do you all still have
debt oh my gosh what talk we ever we do
okay horrible about
how much what's what how much dad do you
think you have right now excluding the
hall out of our adjusted including the
rent yeah uh I'm gonna go with my
figures that don't even include
the rent okay gross income 82% of our
adjusted gross income is swallowed up
and nothing but debt okay all right so
rent or okay all right so here here's
what you guys need to do if I'm in your
shoes sounds like to me you guys aren't
following the baby steps okay Mary the
first one is you want to get a thousand
dollars put away and then outside of
that we're throwing every dollar dime
nickel and penny toward debt like you're
not saving 10 percent of your income
that that's I don't know what process
that is but what you guys have to do is
we got a wrestle free your money that's
going out each and every month building
up the credit card companies legacy and
everybody else's and so that's what you
got to do so you and your husband get
plugged in sit down together and say
okay thousand dollars is put away some
of this little stuff when I was digging
for Chris Brown was to find out Mary and
some of the stuff popping up is it a
want or a need okay because the sale
going on at the mall that's not a need
all right and so so quarterly not okay
so get focused and plug in on the baby
steps honey because they work if you
worked them they will work and so you go
down the aisle there and you pluck them
off Chris what would you say yeah I
think you know one of the things you
said is not working but one thing that
is working is when these things pop up
guess what you've got the money to pay
for these emergencies you're not paying
20% interest on them you're not swiping
a card because you've saved and so to
say that the thousand-dollar mergency
funds not working while I shoot it is
working you're not paying interest on
all that so I want to encourage you in
that and I also want to encourage you
you know make sure that your budgeting
process is tight you know couple of your
answers so far have been a little bit
kind of open-ended like you don't know
the numbers and so just tighten that
down just a tad and you might see some
money that you didn't haven't seen in a
while thank you for the call Mary hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
so you have to break the cycle you have
to flip this thing on its head and make
it behave you've got to get so fired up
and wired up that you're broke friends
think you've lost your mind